very very bad news for Donald Trump
Donald Trump has been caught funneling
donations supposedly for veterans to his
own foundation Trump portrays himself as
the strong pro-military guy he's all
about the veterans but veterans groups
are not unanimously taken with Donald
Trump for example the Iraq and
Afghanistan Veterans of America publicly
rejected donations from Donald Trump
saying quote we need strong policies
from candidates not to be used for
political stunts Trump didn't care
though he went and he set up this
donation website that specifically
promises quote one hundred percent of
your donations will go directly to
veterans needs and he actually used that
found that that uh a decision he made to
skip last week's debate on Fox News
you'll remember Louis he said I'm
holding a rally at the same time as that
debate which I'm skipping and we're
gonna raise money for veterans the
website when you go to it where he's
raising money for veterans is a single
page with stock photos and a credit card
donation form and it says one hundred
percent of your donations will go
directly to veterans needs the problem
is that that is a lie the Weekly
Standard got involved did some math and
they realize that back in 2014 the Trump
foundation donated more money to the
almost universally hated Citizens United
foundation then to veterans group so
they said wait a second that's kinda
weird he says he's all about donating to
veterans didn't really donate very much
to veterans in the past so then they
looked more into last week's campaign
and indeed if you look at the bottom of
that campaign donation website for the
veterans it says the Donald J Trump
foundation is a 501 C 3 nonprofit
organization an email confirmation of
your donation will be sent to the email
address you provide ok fine so the money
is going first to Trump's foundation but
then he could be donating it to veterans
groups right i mean he's probably able
to do that well then it's already a lie
because the donations are not going
directly to veterans they're going to
Trump's foundation and then after
expenses after salaries after whatever
maybe some of it is going to vets well
yes but is that still better than what's
maybe that's the way it has to be done I
don't know do we know that the exact
details of that perhaps because of some
weird regulation or law maybe this is
the way it has to be done if he's
running a campaign absolutely fair
question Lois and I'm glad you brought
it up so let's look at what he has done
in the past claiming that he is a big
supporter veterans a 2015 analysis by
Forbes figured out that barely one
percent of Donald J Trump foundations
5.5 million dollars of donations went to
organizations that support military
veterans so yes Lois Lois looking for
the silver lining it is remotely
possible that monies donated under the
guise of these support the vets things
are getting two veterans minus operating
fees and all that stuff but the money is
going to Donald Trump's personal
foundation which has no history of
significant support of veterans and then
conceivably weird to believe it is all
going to veterans but the idea that it
is going directly to veterans is
absolutely bogus but the reality is is
that this there's a more important thing
than this the reality is that Trump is
using the veterans thing to pander to
potential voters the legality of it
whether it's going directly or
indirectly to veterans or whatever
there's every indication from Trump's
past donation activity that this is not
really that important to him and he's
using it to pander to voters and that's
really the despicable part of it well
when you're running in in as a
Republican date you have to kiss the ass
of veterans pandering is almost a bit a
requisite yes yeah that's true and the
funny thing is that I would say if you
look at voting records anyway most
Republicans in Congress don't really
seem to support veteran benefits or
veteran care they support troops by
giving them Wars to fight they just say
I support the troops I guess that's just
supported the troops right
self-professed that I support the troops
well you also put out you but a ribbon
magnet on your car that's one thing you
can do and you can be made in China
right and an American flag pin on your
suit I guess which now everybody does
the Democrats now everybody has to do it
now because now if
don't have it it's somehow scene is like
a demerit of in some way crazy what's
going on the pandering is crazy talk to
me about this on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash david pakman show
after the break we will talk about this
new trend of the religious right using
exemptions and exceptions and opt outs
the circumvent the law